TURNER: Good evening.
My name's Dennis Turner from the Religious Studies department and the Divinity School.
Dean Attridge, who can't--
and he apologizes for it--
can't be here,
asked me
to do the introduction.
And when he did, I was caused to reflect on the difference in style between the way Brits do it
and the way it's done here.
Terry, you'll remember this.
It works like this in a British university. I would say,
"There is absolutely no need to introduce so famous a person as Terry Eagleton," and I'd sit down,
because there's no need to do it.
However, styles are more elaborate here, and rhetorical, and I thought it better-- I ought to say something.
And, Terry, you will remember 38 years ago,
you and I taught summer school in a place called Manhattanville College.
And there are two things I remember from that. No, three.
One was: every day you got lost between the office and
your classroom.
And we had to go and search for you.
Secondly,
we discovered a most excellent television program called "Sesame Street."
And--
in fact, I seem to remember you rearranging your classes so as to enable us to view it.
Thirdly-- and this is MY memory-- I discovered the dialectic, from you.
And that-- I was caused to think about that by last week's lectures.
Number one,
last Tuesday
was, to me, a perfectly
marvelous re-narration, simply, of the Gospels.
Number two--
number one was with a view to getting
Ditchkins
to upgrade the standards of their critique.
It's fairly clear--
if
it wasn't from
what Terry said--
there's a certain element of a straw man being
knocked down.
The second, on Thursday,
reminded us that
actually the history of the uptake of those Gospels amounts
to a fairly significant series of betrayals, and
thirdly,
that there's something significant about this, that it's not a form of liberal even-handedness-- this has something to do with the
dialectic. Because what was really important about this was
the better critique of institutional Christianity was actually to be found in the Gospels than in
Dawkins and Hitchens.
And that, I think, was something that you also
were saying about capitalism;
it was something you were also saying about America
and American influence in foreign policy,
and I think this is highly significant-- is that
actually
the best form of critique is the auto-critique, which emerges from within the thing
which is being criticized.
That, it seemed to me, said a great deal about,
as it were, the light-handed Marxism which is coming
through,
particularly on Thursday's lectures.
What are we going to get today?
I don't know. I hope Terry does.
But it's supposed to be something in the territory
of faith and reason. Is that not right, Terry?
Over to you.
EAGLETON: And the fourth thing about Manhattanville College, Dennis,
was that-- wasn't it a massively beautiful thing--
these, of course, were the days,
the trendiest post-Vatican-II days,
one could imagine,
1970,
with two hundred nuns--
not, I assure you,
not penguin nuns, you know, but
cigarette-smoking, high-heeled,
be-lipsticked nuns.
Almost
all of whom, I'm sure, now have at least four children and
a very, very nice husband.
And
there was a rather
genial but crazed chaplain,
if I remember,
full of the effervescence of the spirit
and of Vatican II who did
various bizarre masses,
one of which, I think, he was dressed
entirely in newspaper
to-- I think to communicate some point about
communication, or something.
But then the piece de resistance was
the so-called "Mass of the Beautiful
Thing,"
where he asked us, at the end of
the previous week's mass,
to bring next week some beautiful thing,
adding, of course, "Bring yourselves, above all,"
in his pious, phony,
earnest, bogus way.
And
Dennis and I were late for mass and we had
to
find a beautiful thing in about twenty
seconds. We found two identical fir cones
outside the door-- you know,
cones dropped from the fir tree--
and at one point we had solemnly to exchange--
oh, we were asked first of all to
contemplate our beautiful thing, and so
Dennis and I stared long
and blankly at our fir cones. Then
we were asked even to smell them,
and-- but certainly, at one point, to become them.
We both tried to feel suitably small, crinkled, and
dry.
And then we were asked to "exchange our beautiful thing" with another. Whereupon
Dennis and I solemnly exchanged our
identical fir cones.
We will write a book on this at some point before we go.
Yes, I am indeed going to talk about, this time, about faith
and reason.
Something that I think
theologians and theologically minded people
share with political
radicals, and also with
people of a psychoanalytic bent, Freudians and the rest, which is--
the paradox that
without reason,
we're sunk, we're finished.
Yet
reason is not, in the end,
what is most fundamental
about us.
And keeping, as it were,
both sides, both ends of that paradox, keeping a close
hand on both ends,
is pretty difficult.
Richard Dawkins, in "The God
Delusion," claims at one point with grandiloquent folly that
religious faith dispenses with reason altogether,
which wasn't even true
of the thick-
headed clerics
who knocked me around at grammar school,
high school.
Even they didn't claim that they dispensed-- that religion dispensed with reason altogether.
Without-- so the paradox is: without reason, we
perish,
but reason doesn't go all the way down.
A paradox
splendidly, magnificently explored,
I think, in some of the novels of Thomas Mann,
in The Magic Mountain and Doktor Faustus particularly. You can't let go of reason,
but reason
isn't--
will itself dwindle into a kind of
impoverished and brittle rationalism--
of a kind not very far, I think, from Dawkins, at least--
if it isn't, it doesn't recognize that it isn't all there is,
if it doesn't pay its dues,
if it doesn't, so to speak, acknowledge its
loyalty
to some origins beyond itself. Without
reason, then, we perish, but
the paradox is, reason doesn't go all the way down-- even Dawkins
has been known to emerge from his laboratory from
time to time.
And there are even those uncharitable commentators who have detected
the mildest whiff of obsessive irrationalism
in his zealous campaign for
secular rationality.
And another old paradox, of course, is
"Push reason
to a certain limit,
and it capsizes
into its opposite."
It capsizes
into irrationalism.
Dawkins's anti-religioius zeal
makes the Grand Inquisitory
look like a soggy liberal.
Indeed, Dawkins seems to nurture a positively Maoist kind of faith
in faith itself. In the hopelessly
idealist conception, for example, he seems to share
that religious ideology
is what fundamentally drives radical
Islam,
as opposed to, say, material conditions or
some perceived political injustice,
which it seems to be what most radical Islamists say
is their motivation.
Dawkins sweeps that grandly aside in
his obsession with religion,
and talks- and sees radical Islam itself
as, as it were, wholly motivated by religious
ideas. His belief
in the power of religion
is every bit as robust as the Pope's.
To claim that without reason we're sunk, yet
in the end reason isn't where it's at, as it were--
and yet not to cave into
one of the many varieties of irrationalism
is as hard for the political radical
to sustain,
that fine
tension, as I think it is for the
theologian, or, indeed, for the Freudian. To
respect the ego--
Freud, of course, the great rationalist, the great Enlightenment--
radical Enlightenment tradition--
and somebody who recognized, of course,
is not the master of its
own house, who showed us
magnificently
how and why
that was so.
It's only if reason can draw upon resources
more
tenacious and less fragile than itself
that it's capable
of prevailing. It
can't prevail by itself.
That's not to say that somebody else would
prevail. Rather, that for reason itself
to prevail,
it must constantly tap energies, resources, capacities,
which in the end run deeper than reason itself.
And that, I think,
is a truth which liberal rationalism
of a Ditchkens variety
rather disastrously
overlooks.
And that brings us then
to the question of faith and reason, which is not, as
indeed I've tried to intimate
here--
is not just a theological question. What I've said there
obviously has a reach, has a purview
beyond theology itself.
But I'll talk a little bit now about faith and reason
in a theological
sense.
There is probably, I suppose, no greater evidence of Ditchkens's
theological illiteracy
than the fact that he appears
to subscribe to what I previously called
the Yeti
view of faith.
I mean by this, of course, the view
that God is
a sort of object
which, like the Yeti,
or the ley lines, or the Loch Ness monster,
or
the tooth fairy,
or unidentified flying objects--
the evidence so far in
is radically ambiguous,
not to say
deeply dubious.
And because we can't thus demonstrate God's existence in a reasonably straightforward
way
that we can demonstrate the existence of
necrophilia or Michael Jackson--
then
we have to put up with something
less than certainty,
known as faith. Well,
that's the Yeti view of things, shared
as it were, by most atheists, most
agnostics, and, I'm afraid, most Christians too.
I scarcely, of course, need to point out to this
distinguished and
utterly privileged and special company
(he said grovelingly)--
I scarcely need to point out to you what a
travesty
of Christian faith, at least, this is.
So that on the most elementary questions of
the theology
on which he chooses to pronounce with such
portentously self-regarding authority,
Ditchkens is hopelessly at sea. Even, as it were, at square one,
he is.
For one thing, of course, God differs from the--
you know, from unidentified flying objects or the Yeti or the tooth fairy
in not being even a possible object of cognition.
It's just that we don't-- it's not just that we don't happen to be able to see him.
It is, as it were, that our not seeing him
is inherent to God
himself, which is presumably not true
of the Yeti,
if he exists,
or the tooth fairy. I'm sorry for anybody here
who believed in the tooth fairy--
I hasten to add, of course it does exist;
don't worry about that at all.
For another thing,
faith of course is traditionally regarded
as a question of certainty.
Even more scandalously for the Ditchkenses of this world,
not
as a question of probability, or speculation, or guesswork,
but actually as a question of certainty, which is not to say
that it's not also traditionally regarded as being inferior to knowledge, which it is. But only fully
paid-up rationalists
think that nothing is certain
but knowledge.
Faith, as the author of the epistle to the Hebrews writes,
is the assurance of things
hoped for, conviction of things
unseen.
Whatever else may divide science and theology
or religion, it's from a theological view
certainly not the question of certainty.
I don't think Ditchkens understands that in the least.
The certainty in question, to be sure,
is not the same kind of
certainty as that of a well-entrenched scientific observation
like, "It's just turned red"
or
"The mouse is clearly drunk and we are now calling off the experiment" or
"The experimenter is clearly drunk, so the mouse isn't."
It's not a statement of that kind of certainty,
to be sure,
but then neither are statements like, "I love you," which, as
Jonathan Kuller has pointed out, is always a quotation,
the most quoted
piece of language. "I love you." Of course,
however burningly or sincerely it's said,
staring into their eyes at the time, is, of course
the most dreariest of quotations.
Totally intertextual.
It's not-- it's
statements-- certain statements like "I love you"
or, you know,
"Liberal democracy is a lot better than slavery"
or "The overweening Emma Woodhouse finally gets her comeuppance."
There are not statements of a scientific
turn,
but they are pretty certain for most of us, even so.
This isn't to claim,
as Dawkins seems to imagine in the
case of religion,
that what one's really saying there
is that religious propositions don't need evidence at all.
Dawkins makes the disastrous error, I think, of thinking
that to say that they're not scientific
is therefore to say that they're not-- that they
have no concern with the evidential
whatsoever.
If Jesus's body is mingled with the dust of Palestine,
then Christian faith is in vain.
It's rather to suggest that though,
for example,
I must be prepared to explain
at tedious length
what it is about you that I find so lovable,
to give all kinds of reasons for that,
to argue the case,
adducing bodies of evidence, demonstrating
this or that,
arguing over the existence or non-existence of this
particular quality in you.
I'm also forced to recognize that someone else
might see all this as well in you, and not love you
at all.
The evidence itself will not decide the issue.
At some point along the line, a particular
way of seeing the evidence-- one, perhaps, implicit
from the outset--
comes into play,
one which involves a particular kind of personal
engagement with it,
and none of that is reducible
to the evidence itself, in the sense of being in love, to be motivated by
a bare account
of a situation.
One might note, by the way, the difference between
that
image
of faith and
the dubious notion that reason can take us
so far,
after which some kind of existential leap in the dark
proves to be essential.
I don't think that's
the right model.
You can know all you need to know--
as, let's say, a Germanist about the sonnets
to Orpheus--
but this is no guarantee that they won't leave you cold.
The evidence itself, as it were, will not move you,
necessarily, to a certain kind of engagement.
with the object.
And none of that, surely, should strike a scientist, a scientist
like Dawkins,
as unfamiliar.
Because I take it that scientists are,
in an important sense,
not only believers,
but actually, in some sense, aestheticians.
You know, that
elegance in science will get you a very,
very long way.
The universe is a matter of style.
The truth of the universe is a matter of style. All scientists are closet Oscar Wildeans.
And as Rowan Williams remarks, all
communication
involves faith.
All communication involves faith of some kind,
and since reason
is itself, of course, a collaborative and
dialogical and
communicative affair,
and I think that the positivists often go sadly wrong by not seeing that,
by seeing it as a much more, as it were,
monistic affair--
since reason is all a matter,
indissociably a matter, of dialogue and communication,
of collaboration, then--
then if all communication involves faith,
this must
apply to reason
too. Reason
is a dialogue, and dialogues always involve a kind of faith.
Nor, as we know--
another familiar mistake made by
the Ditchkenses of this world--
nor is faith in the first place a matter of subscribing
to the proposition that a supreme being
exists.
For one thing,
God doesn't exist as an entity in the
world--
atheists and believers are
agreed
on this.
And for another thing, as I have argued before,
in these lectures,
faith is in the first place performative
rather than propositional.
Which is not to argue
that it's not
coachable in terms of
propositions or, as we
traditionally say, doctrines.
Just that it's not in the first place
a matter
of descriptions of reality.
It resembles utterances like
"I have faith in you"
more than it does a statement like
"I believe in goblins."
Abraham has faith
but it's surely doubtful that he could even have conceived
of God not existing. He had faith
even so.
The militant left-wing atheist Alain Badiou,
probably the greatest living French philosopher, author
of an absolutely splendid book on St. Paul,
understands this far better
than does
his Anglo-Saxon liberal
rationalist counterparts.
Badiou understands totally--
as a Marxist, or
or ex-Marxist, ex-Maoist, atheist, militant atheist--
that faith articulates a loving commitment
before it counts as a description of the way
things are,
though that it involves a description of the way
things are
is as clear as
the fact that moral imperatives.
do so, must do so, as well.
Propositions that can be true or false have their roots in
kinds of experiences which can't be treated
quite that way, and would not
be authentic
if they didn't have their roots in--
one thinks, perhaps, of the nature of propositions in literature, or in fiction.
Fiction contains all sorts of propositions, doesn't it? You know, that-- you know,
Paris is in France, or whatever, or snow is white.
It would simply be that-- those propositions can be falsified or verified,
it's simply-- it's certainly a fact that partly what we mean by fiction
is that those propositions are not there for their own sake, as
descriptions of the world.
They're there, as it were, as supports to
a kind of rhetorical or performative attitude to the world,
a stance to the world,
which is what actually matters.
That's why so many propositions in fiction can
actually be obviously false, and it
doesn't really make any difference.
Now I've got my pages mixed up again.
Yes, there we go.
Yet, as I say, this is not to say, of course,
that the truth or falsehood of such propositions
pales into nothing
besides the depth of the experience from which
they spring.
A believer, after all,
is someone in love,
observes Kierkegaard in The Sickness Unto Death--
a statement that of course by no means applies only to religious believers.
In St. Augustine's view, one can't arrive at truth except through a kind of love.
For St. Anselm,
reason itself is rooted in God,
so that faith must be reason's foundation.
This is what he means by-- part of what he means,
I suppose,
by his celebrated statement, "I believe
in order to understand."
A proposition which, in a different sense,
many kinds of believers--
socialists or feminists--
could also make.
All reasoning,
as we know,
is conducted within the ambit of some
kind of faith, however
inarticulate it may be.
For Thomas Aquinas, love
precedes truth and is the precondition of it.
We seek truth (for Thomas) because
our material bodies
manifest a built-in,
ineradicable desire for it.
A desire
which, for Aquinas, is the inscription within
us
of divine love.
Without love,
no truth.
Faith, for Christian tradition, is
actually what makes truth possible,
which is true in an everyday sense as well.
I think that faith is what makes truth possible--
there's an oblique relation between that
and Lenin's statement that
theory would never be complete, that you would
never arrive at a complete
formulation of
0:23:31.580,0:23:34.080
theory, Lenin once remarked,
without
the development of a mass political movement--
that is to say,
only on the basis of a sort of practical kind of commitment,
engagement
with reality, politically speaking,
can theory itself--
a correct attempt to describe reality--
come to fruition.
It's because, perhaps, we've come to model
knowledge on things
rather than on
persons,
that we fail to see
this implication
of knowledge
and faith. That, for example,
only by
having faith and trust in
somebody
can we really come to disclose ourself, ourselves,
fully to them,
and therefore be known.
That's one way, perhaps,
among the manifold
number of ways
in which truth and faith go together.
We have to have a certain faith and trust in
somebody else to be able to manifest ourselves
to him or her
in a full kind of way.
This is one of several senses, presumably, in which knowledge and virtue
go together, because that
self-manifestation involves a certain kind
of risk, it involves a certain
courage to do that. As the
Duke
rebukes the slanderous Lucio
in Shakespeare's Measure for Measure,
"Love talks with better knowledge,
and knowledge with dearer love."
In the end,
only love, of which faith (ask Kierkegaard sees)
is one form, the-- somebody, a believer,
is someone in love, as he says--
only-- in the end, only love can
achieve the well-nigh impossible goal
of seeing the situation as it actually
is.
Shorn
of both the deceptive
enchantments
of romance and the
dishevelled fantasies of eros,
love
endures to other, inferior
senses.
Realism, of course, demands all kinds of virtues--
I mean realism in the sense of simply trying to get to see the situation
as it actually is--
demands all sorts of virtues, it's not some sort of clinical
matter.
It demands an openness to being wrong,
a certain humility,
a certain selflessness, a certain
preparedness for collaboration,
a certain generosity of spirit,
a lot of hard labor,
conscientious judgment, and so on.
And for Aquinas all virtues, or such virtues,
have their roots in love.
So love is not irrelevant, and a very
practical issue, as it were, of simply trying
to see the situation as it is
which is of course the basis
of all moral
and political achievement.
The basis of all moral and political achievement is the
humble and essential matter
of trying to see things as they are.
A very, very basic and
low level enterprise
which we have reason to believe may well be impossible. Love
is the ultimate form
of a cold-eyed, soberly disenchanted realism,
which is why it is the twin of truth.
The two--
love and truth-- also have in common
the fact that they are both usually unpleasant.
I mean, radicals are people who hold that truth
is usually a lot less palatable than they want us to believe--
a necessary dash of
paranoia comes in there.
Nothing wrong with a bit of paranoia between
friends, you know?
Just as people who don't believe in conspiracies
are fantasists to the core, are these fantasists who don't believe
in conspiracies. Strange.
And we've seen already, in our discussion of the New Testament, that there's nothing lovely about love.
We've seen just where love is likely to land you.
Pascal comments that the saints, he says, maintain that
we must love things
before we know them. Presumably
because only through a passionate engagement with them
can we come to know them
at all truly.
Dispassionateness is the death of knowledge,
in that sense of the word-- not in every sense of the word-- in that sense of the word,
whatever the liberal may think.
I suppose there are some nowadays who
would regard faith in socialism as even more eccentric
than a belief in the Assumption of the Blessed Virgin
into heaven.
Why, then
do some of us still cling
to this political faith,
in the teeth of what many people would regard as recent
and solid evidence?
Not only, I think, as I said before,
that socialism seems to be such an extraordinarily good idea,
that it's proved exceedingly hard to discredit,
and this despite its own very best efforts to do so. It's
also, I think, not only that. It's because one can't
accept that
for example, the world that we see groaning in agony
around us,
is all there is
or all that could be.
Even though we accept that, empirically speaking,
this might indeed be the case, this is perfectly
possible.
It's also because one gazes with wondering bemusement
upon those hard-headed
types for whom all this,
all we see around us,
perhaps given a reformist tweak or two,
is as good
as it gets.
One finds that utterly bewildering. Because
to back down from this vision would be to betray
what one feels are the most precious powers and capacities
of human beings.
Because however hard one tries, one simply can't shake off the
perhaps primitive or infantile
conviction that this is not how it is supposed to be.
However much we're aware
that this seeing the world in the light of Judgment Day, as Walter Benjamin might put it,
is folly to the wise,
and a stumbling block to stockbrokers--
because there's something in this vision which
calls
to the very depths of our being,
and evokes a passionate
assent there--
because not to feel this would be not to be
oneself-- would be not to be oneself--
because one is too much in love
with this vision of humankind
to back down,
walk away,
settle for half, or take
no
for an answer.
All of which, of course, as we can see from
Death of a Salesman,
from Willy Loman, who is unable to back down,
say no, take no for an answer, settle for half, or walk away,
will lead directly to a certain kind of tragedy, to a kind of
tragic impasse or death. Now,
none of that seems to me to run counter
to reason--
as it would, say,
if the world was already a nuclear wasteland
from which nothing could be salvaged-- then, indeed,
those kinds of
commitment could be said to be unreasonable.
It's just that it's a different kind of thing
from a scientific observation
or an everyday piece of cognition, as
indeed,
Ditchkens's belief in the value
of individual freedom
is different
from a scientific observation. Ditchkens
can't ground
his beliefs
in freedom, in freedom of inquiry,
and the need for rational debate-- he can't
ground those scientifically,
and there's absolutely no reason, in my view,
why he should be required to do so.
These, then,
are perhaps some of the ways in which reason
doesn't go all the way down.
It's also the case, isn't it, that we need commitment to reason itself-- one which is not,
perhaps,
reducible to reason.
We need to be committed to reason.
We can always ask ourselves, for example,
why
discovering the truth
should be thought so desirable?
Some people have thought it wasn't.
Nietzsche didn't think
it was very desirable, necessarily.
Nor, some of the time,
perhaps, did Henrik Ibsen
or Joseph Conrad.
If we want rancor, malice,
resentment, anxiety,
or urged dominion, Nietzsche might inquire
lurks behind this obdurate will to truth.
If we're to defend reason
we must be inspired by more than reason to do so.
There are legitimate disputes, surely,
over the nature and status of rationality itself,
which are far from evolving
any kind of irrationalism.
To what extent, for example, reason encompasses
the aesthetic,
imaginative,
sensuous,
intuitive,
and effectve.
In what sense it might be, as I say, a dialogical affair?
What counts as rational foundation?
Whether reason inherently implicates the values of freedom,
autonomy,
and self-determination?
Whether it's substantive
or procedural,
apodictic
or evidential,
instrumental
or autotelic?
To what extent
it represents in its totalizing and apparently all-explanatory nature
a recycled version
of the very mythologies that
it seeks to oust,
as Adorno and Horkheimer would argue?
Whether, as I said before,
it's to be modeled primarily on our knowledge of things
or our knowledge of persons?
What relations the
rational ego
maintains with the superego, and the primary processes?
What we make of the fact that even before
we've started to reason,
the world is in principle intelligible to us
in the first place?
What if it wasn't?
Could we imagine that?
Whether it's true that we reason as we do
primarily because of what we do?
Whether reason is to be associated with common
sense and moderation,
as it is
with the liberal rationalists,
or with
revolution,
as it was by John Stuart Mill
and the Jacobins?
Whether reason only takes flight at dusk,
whether it's to be contrasted with our animality,
or seen as an integral part of it?
And so on. Many questions we could raise
about the status of nature,
of rationality, its relation to other things.
For Aquinas, to revert to him once again,
and to quote
Dennis Turner,
rationality is the form of our animality.
Bodiliness is the stuff
of our intellectual being.
Theology
in that sense is a species
of materialism.
We reason as we do
because of the kind of material creatures
that we are.
We're reasonable
because we're animals,
not despite
being so.
If an angel could speak,
we would not be able to understand what he said.
It's hard to feel that such considerations
lie at the forefront of the mind of Richard Dawkins,
whose callow
rationalistic complacency
is of just the sort that Jonathan Swift
so magnificently savaged.
Swift, a rationalist, as has been said, who didn't believe in reason.
It's equally hard to think that those questions
have ben much brooded over by Christopher Hitchens.
In Robert Bolt's play, A Man For All Seasons,
Thomas More advances a very Catholic defense of reason.
Man, he says,
has been created by God to serve him
in the wit and tangle and cunning
of his mind.
Not simply in simplicity like the flowers, for example,
but in the very cunning and deviousness
of his intellect. That itself is a kind of
service of God.
When a new version of the Oath of Allegiance
to the King is published,
More eagerly asks his daughter Susanna
what the wording is. And his daughter Susanna replies in rather
Protestant style,
"Oh, Daddy, what do the words matter?"
To which More replies, in his good old materialistic,
Papistical way,
"An oath is made of words. I may be able to take it." Yet
it's the same More,
a stickler for the material,
the same More who, pressed by
the exasperated
Susanna
on why he won't declare his loyalty to the King,
berated by Susanna because-- she says,
"Daddy, it just isn't reasonable"--
replies, "Well, in the end, it isn't a matter of reason.
In the end, it's a matter of love."
All reasoning is carried on within some
kind of faith,
including the faith in reason itself.
For the philosopher Fichte,
faith, though not necessarily of the religious variety,
is prior to and foundational of
all knowledge.
Knowledge moves within the assumptions, as we know,
which are embedded in our practical bound-up-ness with the world,
and which can never be precisely
formalized
or thematized.
AS Wittgenstein remarks in On Certainty,
it is what we do
that lies at the bottom of
our language games.
Know-how
precedes knowledge,
and never ceases to underpin it.
This is not to concur
with the
postmodern pragmatists and relativists,
that reason
is therefore too much on the inside of our way of life
ever to operate as an effective critique of it. I mean
that
argument might
be thought to follow
from the idea that reason,
the roots of reason run down to what we do
run down to our ways
of doing things, our ways
of carving up the world.
All right,
the postmodern pragmatist might say
that means that reason is absolutely bound up with our culture, is, as it were, on the inside of it,
and therefore the idea that reason could ever
put enough
daylight between itself and
what we do to operate
as a critique
of what we do
is an entire
fantasy. Reason would there have to be
standing at some Olympian or
Archimedean point
which simply doesn't exist in the first place.
Well, I don't think that's right, I think that's
a mistake.
This is the idea that the criteria
which determine
what is to count as reasonable
must themselves be derived
from the very form of life
that they seek to put under critical scrutiny. The
very criteria which, to
count as what is reasonable,
and therefore which seem to offer a kind of
overview,
a monitoring of our way of life,
actually themselves, according to this view, are drawn from our way of life
and have no
basis in any other
place.
I think what that forgets, among other things,
is that
it's part of the way
in which the human animal is actually bound up
with the world,
that it's able to distance itself from it.
Not least by labor and language.
It's not the kind of
bogus
transcendence that we can leap out of our skins
and leap out of our world.
It's actually part of the way we're in the world
as laboring, linguistic
creatures,
communicative creatures, relational creatures--
that we're able, to some degree, to get kind of fixed
upon it in the way
that it seems
squirrels and goldfish
can't. I don't wish to
be odiously patronizing or condescending
to squirrels, or goldfish, you know,
they're my
best friends,
I just want to say-- they just don't look as though they're engaging in a ferocious fundamental critique,
you know, of the world that they're
actually a part of. And of course, because they're not, they are
marvelously safe.
Because they're so integrated with their environments,
because they're not cursed and blessed with that awful
double-edged sword called language,
or developed consciousness,
they're not capable,
you know, of bringing themselves, of overreaching
themselves, and bringing themselves to
nothing,
as a linguistic animal alone is.
So the doxa, or implicit certainties, or taken-for-granted truths,
which constitute the matrix of all our more formal
reasoning,
are as obvious in the case of science, I suppose,
as much as anywhere else.
This much at least, one might say,
the postmodern skeptics have
going for them
where it comes to science,
though one should bear in mind
that humanists have always been prejudiced against scientists.
It's just that over the years
they've shifted their grounds
for this. I mean, scientists used to be-- you know, in my day,
scientists used to be regarded as unspeakable
oiks with dandruff on their collar and leather patches on their sports jackets'
elbows
who thought that Rimbaud
was a cinematic strong man
rather than a French poet.
They've now become, for a later
epoch, the authoritarian custodians of
absolute truth. Yes. The
peddlers now
of the postmodern objection to science,
of an obnoxious ideology known as objectivity,
a notion which simply tars up the ideological
prejudices
with an acceptably disinterested
guise.
Interestingly, one thing that's happened in our time
is that the
burden of the critique of science, the resistance to science,
has shifted from a tradition humanism
to a kind of culturalism.
Culturalism is now
one of a long series, a rather dishonorable series,
of critics of science.
Culturalism, I mean
that intellectually violent attempt
to repress or eradicate nature
altogether
in the name of culture.
One doesn't need to subscribe, of course, to the absurd caricature
to note that science, like every other human
practice
is indeed shot through with prejudice
and partisanship and unthematizable
assumptions,
unconscious biases, beliefs too close to the eyeball to be objectified, and so on.
If the Virgin Mary
were to put in an appearance at this very moment over the skies in
New Haven,
clutching the baby jesus with one hand and
nonchalantly distributing 100 dollar notes with the other,
it would be more than the reputation of anybody
laboring away on the Yale laboratories was worth
even fractionally to put their heads out of the window.
There are still, in other words,
a good many telescopes up which
science
is churlishly disinclined
to peer.
There are those topics which in a Foucaultian phrase are in the truth,
in the truth
at any given time,
and those which happen not to be
in the truth at a particular time.
Marxism
used to be in the truth, quite recently;
it isn't now.
It's not so much that it's run out of facts; it's that
it's out of favor.
I happen to know, for example, as a fact
that the moon
deeply affects human behavior.
Since I'm a mild kind of lunatic,
I'm always aware of when the moon
is full,
even without looking,
if I don't go quite as far as baying or
sprouting hair on my cheeks.
But I doubt that any scientist who valued
their corporate grants would fall over themselves
to investigate this remarkably well-researched,
well-evidenced phenomenon.
It would be rather like a literary
critic publishing a three-volume work on
Goosy Goosy Gander, yes.
Though Dawkins's The God Delusion
is astonishingly tightly,
astonishingly laconic about
the cock-ups and
catastrophes of science--
Dawkins castigates the Inquisition, but not Hiroshima--
not the world that science has actually helped to create.
Most of us are
surely aware that like almost any interesting human pursuit, from staging a play
to running the economy,
science is a lot more dicey and precarious,
anomalous, and serendipitous
than its publicity agents would prefer us to think,
and that many of its practitioners will go
to quite extraordinary lengths
to preserve
a tried and trusted
hypothesis.
None of that is in my view
to discredit
that loving,
passionate, selfless,
faithful, exhausting,
profoundly ethical labor
known as trying to get it right.
In political life, it's a labor
which can make the difference between life and death.
It's also one which, for all its necessary
demythologizing,
could be said to have religious roots.
Charles Taylor
has pointed out how the scientifically detached
or disinterested
subject of modernity
has its historical origins, or some of them,
in premodern
religious
asceticism,
with its contemptuous mundi,
in order to know the world
in strange irony,
you must at the same time reject it.
In a similar way, Heidegger regards the Cartesian notion of certainty
as a hangover from the certainty of
religious faith.
Even so, yet
the fact remains that there are those for the sake of whose flourishing
and--
those who for the sake of their flourishing and well-being
need to know
more or less how things stand with them.
Not everybody. Not everyone needs to know that.
But there are those people
so placed in society
that in order to flourish and to have some well-being,
they need to know, rather insistently,
on how things stand with them.
And there are those rather more privileged souls,
some of them known as postmodernists, for whom this represents, simply,
an ideological illusion.
Some people need knowledge in order to
do important things with it
and others don't.
So science is, to that extent, surely about faith as well,
which is not all it shares in common
with theology.
Rather, as the church is largely said to have betrayed
the historical mission,
so, one might argue,
has a great deal of science.
I myself was twenty years
a fellow of Wadham College, Oxford,
an institution which in the late seventeenth century
was home to the Royal Society,
one of whose founders, John Wilkins,
was the Warden of Wadham,
and was the brother-in-law
of Oliver Cromwell.
Unlike most of the rest of Oxford,
the College was on the progressive side of the Civil War,
and suffered rather badly for it,
and Wadham's rather traditionally dissident
politics
lasted as long as into the twentieth century
in the form of a kind of Bloomsbury
liberalism, basically reflected by
its
twentieth century Warden Sir Maurice Bowra
who was rash enough to
take me on as a young Fellow,
largely, I think, because he fancied me, in fact, but--
something that I feel rather
disreputable about. My career, you know, is based upon the
attractions of a rather elderly Bloomsbury person.
I really don't like to think about that too much. I'd like to think it was
part of my merit that I was elected an Oxford Fellow, you know, not just for
disreputable reasons of this kind.
All of this had its roots in
this revolutionary
scientific lineage, which of course is
part of a history which those today who are sometimes rather glibly critical of science seem to forget, rather conveniently,
a lineage which prized fidelity to one's reasoning, experience,
and independent good sense
over loyalty to prelate
and monarch.
The fact that, like religion, much of scientific practice
has betrayed its own revolutionary impulses,
is becoming the obedient tool of corporate interests,
shouldn't induce us, I think, to forget
this emancipatory history.
I had more things to say,
but not all that much, actually.
I had-- I was going to go on to talk about
how far faith is
something that we choose,
how far we find ourselves, as it were--
what we find ourselves believing something,
what that means,
or whether that's deterministic or not.
But I've said enough, so I will
open it to discussion if I may. Thank you.